nach dem drop off haben sich die seven
vs wild Teilnehmer als allererstes einen
Überblick über ihre Spots verschafft
doch was würde ein absoluter Profi dann
als erstes tun um sein Überleben zu
sichern Nahrung Shelter oder doch
vielleicht Trinkwasserversorgung wir
finden es gemeinsam mit Tomek elroid von
Wild survival in diesem Video heraus
schon beim Scouting hat survival Experte
Tom mcarroid dabei geholfen die
richtigen Spots zu finden seine
Techniken welcher unter anderem von
verschiedensten indigenen Völkern
gelernt hat gibt er nun seit über 25
Jahren an die größten zwei mit TV Shows
weiter und glücklicherweise nicht nur an
TV-Shows sondern eben auch an uns an
einem Spot auf Island José der den der
Teilnehmer ähnelt wird er uns zeigen was
für ihn die allerersten die wichtigsten
Schritte sind um das Überleben auf einer
einsamen Insel zu garantieren
wenn ich an meinem Strand ankomme muss
ich als allererstes einen Shelter bauen
falls ich diesen Schritt überspringen
sollte kommt im Zweifel ein Sturm auf
oder ich werde von Käfern und Insekten
zerbissen meine oberste Priorität ist
also einen Schalter zu bauen etwas vom
Boden wegzukommen und mich vor Regen zu
schützen
wenn man einen Unterschlupf sucht ist
die Lage das erste woran man denken muss
hier sehen wir Spuren von Wildschweinen
die sich hier am Strand aufhalten
sie stellen mitunter die größte Gefahr
dieser Insel da da sie dich mit ihren
riesigen Hauern aufschlitzen können das
ist nun aber mein Spot und meine
Situation und damit werde ich jetzt
leben müssen normalerweise würde ich
meinen Shelter natürlich nicht inmitten
einer wildschweinfährte Aufbauen der
wiegt bestimmt 70 Kilo aber damit werde
ich zurechtkommen müssen
an neuen Orten muss man sich immer
fragen was gibt es hier noch welche
anderen Informationen kann ich aus der
Umgebung gewinnen auch wenn mein Fokus
auf dem Shelter liegt schaue ich mich um
hier habe ich gerade kroati-spuren
gefunden besser bekannt als der
südamerikanische Nasenbär versteckt sich
gerne in kleinen Höhlen wenn ich mich
später ums Essen kümmere baue ich hier
eine Falle aber jetzt zurück zum
Unterschlupf
ab jetzt hast du 30 Minuten Zeit um
deinen Schalter zu bauen okay
erstmal baue ich das Gerüst ich habe nur
30 Minuten also wird der Shelter nicht
hübsch werden es fällt erstmal nur Regen
ab leider habe ich keine Zeit in den
Bäumen zu bauen um von den Käfern
wegzukommen also ist Regen erstmal mein
Fokus das Gerüst besteht aus zwei
Astgabeln ich sehe gerade keine Pflanzen
um ein Seil herzustellen deswegen sind
Astgabeln die beste Option
die wichtigste Regel beim shelterbau ist
klein ist hübsch
je kleiner der Shelter desto weniger
Material braucht man um ihn abzudecken
oft wollen Menschen einfach groß bauen
damit sie darin rumlaufen können
dabei werden sie aber vor
Sonnenuntergang niemals fertig also baue
ich nur einen sehr sehr kleinen
Wetterschutz etwas super simples damit
ich ihn rasch mit Palmenblättern
bedecken kann
ich sage immer das Shelter die
wichtigste Priorität ist bist du den
bloßen Elementen ausgesetzt bringt dich
das am schnellsten um man stirbt schon
nach wenigen Stunden bei Kontakt mit den
Elementen selbst dann warmen Orten wie
diesem
bist du nass riskierst du schon bei 10
Grad Celsius eine Unterkühlung dich vor
den Elementen zu schützen ist also deine
wichtigste Aufgabe besonders hier in den
Tropen kann es tagsüber wunderschön und
perfekt sein aber in der Nacht zur Hölle
werden gibt es einen Grund warum Du
genau diesen Baum benutzt
nein aber der Baum ist lang und gerade
was ihn zum Bauen geeignet macht und
seine dünnen Äste kann man leicht
durchtrennen man sollte auf dicke Stämme
verzichten da braucht man einfach zu
lang
würde ich totes Holz nutzen anstatt
dieser frischen Äste könnte ich dieses
Schalter wahrscheinlich sogar ohne
Machete bauen
Frischholz ist aber stabiler da ist noch
nicht fault einer Machete ist also von
großem Vorteil neben einem Insektennetz
wäre sie der eine Gegenstand den ich
hier draußen mitnehmen würde Thomas
gestern nämlich gesagt das nervigste
sind einfach nur die Viecher alles
andere kann man irgendwie aushalten er
sagte die Viecher sind das dass ich am
Ende zum Aufgeben
also interessant sein sein Gegenstand
wäre auf jeden Fall Moskitonetz oder
irgendwas ähnliches gibt es einen Grund
warum du am Strand und nicht im
Dschungel brauchst
in der sandflohsaison den Shelter am
Strand zu bauen ist wahrscheinlich nicht
die beste Idee wer am Strand baut wird
früher oder später von Flöhen zerbissen
im Best Case Szenario würde ich mich in
den Wald zurückziehen weil es dort viel
weniger Insekten gibt wegen des
Zeitlimits bleibe ich hier in der Nähe
meiner Ressourcen denn wenn ich hunderte
Meter im Inland baue müsste ich die
ganze Zeit hin und her laufen da reicht
eine halbe Stunde nicht ehrlich gesagt
bin ich lieber klitschnass als von
Flöhen zerbissen
was noch 15 Minuten
als nächstes stapelt man so viele
Palmenblätter wie möglich aufeinander
ich habe keine Zeit sie zu flechten wenn
ich sie jetzt einfach drauflegen würde
sammelt sich der Regen in den Blättern
und kann nicht richtig abfließen ich
musste im Wasser eine Richtung geben ich
habe das früher mit der Machete gemacht
bis ein Freund meiner Frau meinte wieso
machst du das nicht so
genau dadurch haben wir so was wie
Schindeln und die Blätter zeigen alle
nach unten
wenn ich die Blätter staple achte ich
darauf dass die Rinne des Blattes nach
oben zeigt so dass das Wasser dort
durchfließen kann
also er macht jetzt was was wir
wahrscheinlich von den Teilnehmern
selten sehen werden er wird jetzt einmal
hochklettern und so ein paar
Blätter sich abschlagen Palmwedel
Bau etwas Kleines hässliches und
schnelles und du wirst überleben kümmer
dich nicht um Komfort sondern darum wie
du dich vor den Elementen schützen
kannst viele schauen sich in Schelte an
und Denken hey sieht doch ganz gut aus
ich sehe viele Blätter das wird schon
reichen es ist das allerschlimmste hier
nur halbherzig zu arbeiten
wenn ich weiß dass die Nacht kalt oder
nass wird mache ich nichts anderes als
Blätter auf meinem Dach anzuhäufen wenn
erstmal was liegt lege ich noch was zum
Beschweren drauf damit mir die Blätter
nicht wegfliegen wenn es stürmt
alles klar die Zeit ist um
wie man sieht ist es nicht besonders
schön es ist auch nicht groß es ist sehr
ungemütlich aber es hält mich am Leben
und das ist der einzige Gedanke den man
in dieser Situation haben sollte also
wenn ich weitermachen würde und ich mehr
Zeit hätte würde ich noch mehr Blätter
zusammenstecken um Wände zu bauen
wenn ich mehr Platz hätte würde ich
versuchen ein Bett mit etwas Erhöhung zu
bauen
dazu noch ein paar Palmenblätter damit
es etwas gemütlicher ist und mich von
dem Sand und dem kalten Boden weg hält
um einen Sturm auszuhalten braucht es
noch ein bisschen mehr zum Beispiel
durch dicke Äste zum Stabilisieren das
ganze ist jetzt schon relativ
wasserdicht ich denke noch eine halbe
Stunde Palmenblätter aufhäufen macht den
Shelter dann komplett dicht wird die
Teilnehmer die sieben Tage durchstehen
wenn sie sich sowas bauen nun wenn ich
hier für sieben Tage draußen wäre würde
das nicht reichen oft kommt man in eine
survival-situation und realisiert das
erst eine halbe Stunde bevor die Sonne
untergeht dann muss man einfach etwas
Schnelles bauen um zu überleben für
sieben Tage würde das aber nicht reichen
die Viecher zerstechen dich und man wird
noch nass
mit mehr Zeit würde ich den Shelter noch
größer machen und die Öffnung schließen
das ist ein täglicher konstanter Prozess
dem Shelter ein paar Stunden zu widmen
Fehler auszubessern ihn zu vergrößern
und gemütlicher zu machen
das hier ist erstmal nur zum Überleben
also es war nie wirklich fertig ja ich
habe ein Jahr im Wald gelebt und in
jeder Woche habe ich Blätter gesammelt
um meinen Schalter zu verbessern ihn
wasserdichter zu machen und ihn mehr zu
dämmen
die Blätter hören nie aufzuwelten
kleiner zu werden und zu verrotten es
ist ein konstanter Prozess
hoffentlich kann sich jeder ein bisschen
Zeit nehmen um ihr Schalter zu
verbessern
eine der wichtigsten Dinge in einer
survival-situation ist ein Seil
herzustellen etwas zu haben um deinen
Shelter zu befestigen um deine fallen
herzustellen oder Sachen über dem Feuer
zu braten das ist eine der besten
Pflanzen dafür
die Rinde in Essen kann sehr stabil sein
hier kann man den Stock einfach in der
Mitte teilen hier ein Korbmacher Trick
denn sich die Mitte zur einen Seite
verlagert zieht man einfach mehr an der
anderen um den Riss wieder mittig zu
bekommen
in der Mitte hat man das Holz und darum
die Rinde aus welcher man ein tolles
Seil machen kann
jetzt kann ich es einfach wickeln und
meinen Shelter stabilisieren einen
Feuerbohrer herstellen oder einen Fisch
über ein Feuer hängen
allerhand Anwendungsmöglichkeiten
ich könnte es auch weiter aufteilen und
Flechten um noch ein stärkeres Seil
draus zu machen hi hier ist noch mal Tom
von wandermut geht's dir vielleicht
gerade genauso wie uns und du hast
richtig Bock dich mal selbst auf einer
einsamen Insel aussetzen zu lassen genau
das kannst du jetzt beim wandermut
Island survival machen dort wirst du
ausgesetzt im Team und mit Survival
Instructor wie beispielsweise im Tom der
bringt dir bei wie du auf so einer
einsamen Insel überleben würdest und vor
allem wie du so eine Insel wieder
verlassen kannst wichtig für solche
Abenteuer ist natürlich die richtige
Ausrüstung deswegen nutzen wir
mittlerweile unsere geballte Erfahrung
von verschiedensten Expeditionen und
entwickeln unsere eigene
Outdoorbekleidung das Beste ist mit
jeder Bestellung hast du die Chance
dieses goldene Ticket zu gewinnen bei
dem du bei einem Abenteuer deiner Wahl
dabei sein kannst klick jetzt auf den
ersten Link in der videob Beschreibung
Check unsere Website aus welche
Abenteuer wir geplant haben und welche
autobekleidung für dich passt und sicher
dir die Chance auf das goldene Ticket im
Wert von 5000 Euro und jetzt viel Spaß
beim weiterschauen
meine nächste Priorität ist Wasser
trinkt man 24 Stunden kein Wasser
funktioniert das Hirn nicht mehr richtig
man trifft dumme Entscheidungen die
schlechte Situationen zu tödlichen
machen wir werden uns die hauptsächlich
auf Kokosnüsse konzentrieren und ich
zeige euch wie man eine Kokosnuss mit
einer Machete oder sogar einem Stock
öffnet ich klettere hier einfach auf die
Palme der Trick dabei ist Druck ich
klammere mich mit den Händen fest an den
Stamm drücke mich mit den Füßen aber
gleichzeitig von ihm ab und dieser Druck
hält mich am Baum los geht's
das war knapp
die obersten Kokosnüsse der Palme tragen
hauptsächlich Wasser und Zucker in sich
die haben wenig Fleisch dafür bestehen
sie fast ausschließlich aus purem Wasser
wenn das Wasser zu ölig wird was bei
älteren Kokosnüssen passiert kann es
sein dass man Durchfall bekommt wenn man
10 oder mehr von ihnen am Tag trinkt
auch wenn man dieses Wasser trinken kann
würde ich davon abraten im Idealfall
suchst du dir Kokosnüsse die auf der
Spitze des Baumes hängen diese sind viel
frischer und man kann sie leicht mit
einem Schlag auf einen Stein oder einer
Machete öffnen
öffne den Deckel pures Wasser
okay wir haben unsere Checkliste
abgearbeitet Shelter Wasser Feuer und
Essen sind unsere Prioritäten jetzt
brauchen wir noch Feuer das wird das
Wasser reinigen unser Essen kochen und
uns helfen unsere Werkzeuge herzustellen
das hier ist ein super-baum den du hier
überall finden kannst wir nennen es
Heidi Heidi auch bekannt als
meeresshibiskus oder Maho das Holz ist
unheimlich leicht und eignet sich sehr
gut um mit einem bowdrill Feuer zu
starten wenn man also schnell ein Feuer
machen will ist das eins der besten
Hölzer die man finden kann was auch cool
ist die Rinde ist sehr faserig und wenn
man den inneren Teil nimmt den man
cambiumring nennt und ihn so in den
Händen reibt werden die Fasern wirklich
fein
sobald ein winziger Funke vom Boje mit
den feinen Fasern in Berührung kommt
geht das Feuer quasi von alleine an
das raucht schon
wir haben gerade versucht einen Funken
mit einem feuerflug zum laufen zu
bekommen das Holz ist aber etwas nass
wir versuchen es noch mal mit einem
baudrill ich habe gerade durch Zufall
diesen Stock gefunden der sich ziemlich
perfekt für einen baujel eignet
erstmal bauen wir den unteren Teil
sie bei jedem reibungsfeuer brauchen wir
so viel Geschwindigkeit und Druck wie es
geht
und was wir hier machen um
Geschwindigkeit und Druckaufbau zu
können ist einfach den Stock so schnell
es geht zu drehen
das Holz ist aber etwas feucht
vielleicht funktioniert es also nicht
aber wenn ich einfach stark drücke und
schnell drehe macht es schon mal viel
raus
die Glut fliegt überall hin deswegen
muss ich jetzt eine Kerbe machen in der
sich die Glut sammeln kann dann müssen
wir die Glut auf sehr trockene Kokos
oder hibiskusfasern legen um das Feuer
anzupusten
normalerweise lege ich die Utensilien
einfach für eine Stunde in die Sonne
damit Sie wirklich durchtrocknen
hoffentlich können wir genug Hitze
erzeugen damit es Staub abwirft wodurch
wir dann ein winziges Stück glühende
Kohle haben
wenn es jetzt so weitergeht müssen wir
es eigentlich nur noch in einen Haufen
Fasern legen einfach genau in die Mitte
dann vorsichtig einpacken und versuchen
die Hitze mit möglichst vielen Fasern in
Kontakt zu bringen
ja Wahl wir haben ein Feuer ja Esel
fühlt sich gut an
da wir nun einen Shelter Wasser und
Feuer haben wissen wir dass wir nächste
Woche vielleicht sogar drei Wochen
überleben können wenn man also diese
drei Dinge hat wird man überleben ab dem
Punkt kommt es eigentlich nur noch auf
die Psyche an ab jetzt geht es nur noch
ums Essen und einfach seine Situation
mit den begrenzten Mitteln angenehmer zu
machen
das Gute am Meer ist dass man nicht
lange suchen muss um Nahrung zu finden
wenn man am Strand feststeckt findet man
tausende Kalorien direkt um sich herum
neben Kokosnüssen gibt es jede Menge
Meereslebewesen an den Riffs wenn man
also eine Angelschnur oder eine Speer
gun hat wird man auf jeden Fall gut
versorgt sein sogar direkt hier vor mir
gibt es sogenannte Napfschnecken das
sind Schalentiere die sind sehr
nährstoffreich und schmecken sogar
richtig gut obwohl sie sch Aussehen
außerdem eignen sie sich gut als Köder
man sammelt einfach alle Schnecken hier
in der Brandung und legt sie falsch
herum ins Feuer bis sie anfangen zu
kochen dann sind sie perfekt und
wirklich gut essbar vermutlich müsste
man nicht einmal Fisch fangen oder
Kokosnüsse pflücken sondern könnte
einfach von den Schnecken hier leben die
Jungen Grünen Kokosnüsse sind perfekt
zum Trinken geeignet die braunen älteren
fürs Essen wenn man keine Machete hat
kann man einfach einen Stopp nehmen ihn
am Riff anspitzen und fest in den Boden
rammen
weil wir jetzt aber eine Machete haben
schaffen wir diesen Ast einfach während
der noch am Baum ist
tatsächlich ist es einfacher die älteren
Kokosnüsse an so einem spitzen Ast zu
öffnen als mit einer Machete die Arbeit
muss man sich dann auch nur einmal
machen und hat den Ast immer
einsatzbereit außerdem bekommt man die
Kokosnuss freigelegt ohne sie zu teilen
wenn ich also eine Kokosnuss öffnen muss
habe ich das hier und bin sofort
einsatzbereit
einige der Kandidaten werden nicht in
der Lage sein auf Kokospalmen zu
klettern um die Grünen Kokosnüsse vom
Baum zu holen weswegen sie mit diesen
älteren braunen klarkommen müssen die
enthalten sehr viel Öl also auch viele
Kalorien trinkt man zu viele alte
bekommt man Durchfall
sie sind gut zum Essen und okay zum
trinken aber man kann nicht 20 davon pro
Tag trinken vier oder fünf am Tag sind
vielleicht noch okay aber man sollte
wirklich versuchen an die frischen
grünen zu kommen solltest du aber nur
eine alte haben gibt es einen guten
Trick um sie auf dem eben vorbereiteten
Ast zu öffnen dafür schaut man einfach
wo das Ende ist mit dem sie am Baum
hängen dort ist Kokosnuss am meisten
also werde ich die Kokosnuss dort
aufbrechen
dann nutzt man einen Klopfer und achtet
darauf dass der Pfahl wirklich in der
Kokosnuss steckt danach Rolle ich sie um
die Schale abzubekommen
die Kokosnuss hat drei Kanten und wenn
ich alle abhole komme ich an die Nuss im
Inneren
woran man auch denken muss sind die
Fasern aus ihnen kann man Seil machen
welches resistent gegen Salzwasser ist
deswegen haben Piratenschiffe früher
kokosseile genutzt damit sie auf See
nicht verfaulen
schaut mal die Kokosnuss hat drei Löcher
auf der Oberseite normalerweise sind
zwei davon sehr hart und eins weicher
also nimmt man einen Stock und stochert
in alle bis man das weiche Loch findet
das ist das Loch wo die Kokosnuss
sprießen würde und wenn man diesen
weichen Mund findet kann man der Linie
zwischen den beiden hakenaugen folgen
dann schlägt man mit einem Stein oder
der Rückseite der Machete genau in die
Mitte dieser Linie und die Kokosnuss
teilt sich genau in zwei seht ihr dieser
Riss der genau hier entsteht
und jetzt haben wir Trinkwasser immer
erst riechen den Fehler macht man nicht
zweimal
genau und hier ist das Kokosfleisch und
weil es eine ältere Kokosnuss ist hat
sie 800 bis 1000 Kalorien theoretisch
braucht man täglich nur zwei davon um
genug Kalorien zum Überleben zu erhalten
ich schneide hier einfach ein großes
Stück raus
wir halten eine Menge Kalorien und habe
auch noch zwei Schüsseln zum Kochen
das hier ist die gelbe mom bin oder auch
schweinepflaume wenn die Frucht orange
und oval ist ist es eine gelbe Mond bin
für unerfahrene könnte sie aussehen wie
der todes- oder manchenellapfel der
todesapfel ist immer grün und rund so
wissen wir dass das hier eine mom bin
ist
schmeckt wie Mango und ist richtig
lecker wenn sie reif ist
wahrscheinlich die beste Frucht die man
finden kann wenn man hier in der Wildnis
ist
richtig geil hier ist sowas wie so ein
Kern drin also hat jetzt nicht so viel
Fleisch wie es aussieht aber schmeckt
richtig gut hammer geil irgendwie eine
Pflaume oder so sagt
er das das Ding ist problematisch wird
halt da wo man nicht weiß dass und ob
man es essen kann es gibt natürlich
Möglichkeiten das herauszufinden aber
hier auf dieser Insel ist es entweder
sehr lecker und sehr frisch oder tödlich
wenn man in einer neuen Umgebung ist und
sich nicht mit den heimischen Pflanzen
auskennt passiert es schnell dass man
sich vergiftet viele Spezialisten sagen
ach probier einfach ein bisschen spuck
es aus und warte was passiert
das funktioniert hier nicht das ist
einer der tödlichsten Bäume der Welt das
hier ist also jetzt der manche Nell Baum
oder todesapfel nur einer dieser kleinen
Äpfelchen tötet dich wenn man ihn ist
wenn also Überlebenskünstler denken das
sieht aus wie ein Apfel ich probiere
einfach mal bringt sie ein kleiner
Fehler ins Grab das muss jedem bewusst
sein das Äpfelchen schmeckt erst super
süß man denkt sich lecker innerhalb
einer Minute fängt der Mund an zu
brennen und plötzlich werden deine
Innereien einfach zerfressen
außerdem darf man auch nicht unter dem
Baum schlafen wenn es regnet das
herunterprasselnde Wasser würde die Haut
verbrennen super super giftig immerhin
ist es leicht zu identifizieren solange
man aufpasst was man tut auch wenn es
gut ist vom Strand wegzukommen
präsentiert der Dschungel auch eine
Vielzahl an gefahren die größte ist
wahrscheinlich das Wildschwein am Strand
sieht man sie am wenigsten kommen wenn
man im Dschungel ist kann man von ihm
überrascht und durchbohrt werden es gibt
außerdem Wespen gefährliche Klippen und
eine Menge giftige Pflanzen
die Fauna und Flora zu kennen ist also
entscheidend
weitere Gefahren am Wasser sind
Krokodile Haie und definitiv giftige
Schlangen
sie stellen nicht die größte Gefahr da
aber man sollte sich ihre Existenz immer
bewusst sein die wahrscheinlichste
Verletzung die sich die Teilnehmer
zuziehen werden sind Schnittwunden wenn
sie auf dem Riff ausrutschen also
Verletzungen die sie selbst verschulden
das Riff besteht aus Vulkangestein und
ist extrem scharf wenn man ausrutscht
und sich schneidet heißt das Game Over
es ist super gefährlich hier und ein
kleiner Fehler kann einem das Leben
kosten Regel Nummer eins ist auf sich
selbst aufzupassen alles langsam und
gewissenhaft anzugehen wenn man sich nur
eine kleine Schnittwunde in dieser
Umgebung zuzieht und unbekannte
Bakterien in den Körper gelangen kann
sich das Entzünden und in einer
Blutvergiftung enden und wenn das nicht
direkt behandelt wird kann man
schlimmstenfalls sogar sterben
also danke fürs anschauen natürlich ist
das nur ein kurzer Überblick und man
muss einiges mehr an Arbeit reinstecken
um zu überleben wir haben Shelter Wasser
Feuer und Nahrung und heruntergebrochen
ist das genau das was die Teilnehmer von
Seven vs wild machen müssen vielleicht
bekommen sie das mindeste davon was ich
hier gemacht habe hin
checkt gerne meinen Channel aus Tom
McElroy und besucht meine Website well
survival skills.com ich freue mich auf
seven vs wild das wird mega definitiv
eine Herausforderung aber eher eine
mentale Challenge wenn man diese
Fähigkeiten hat